bonjour et lieu rodriguez perdomo merci
de répondre à nos questions sur arte
france la france via décret donc vient
d'accepter l'envoi de médecins cubains
dans ces départements d'outre-mer
c'était une demande des médecins entier
bonjour dont vous gérez une gentille ont
entretenu des bons relations et la
france une relation des relations
bilatérales positives depuis longtemps
nous travaillons pour lé renforcement de
la coopération y compris dans les
domaines de la santé et cuba a exprimé
sa volonté de coopérer avec les
départements français des caribous y
compris dans le domaine de la santé nous
allons dit que nous sommes prêts à
étudier des demandes pour coopérer
évidemment pouvait pas ensemble à
l'épidémie du curry 19
comment est ce que vous expliquez que
paris est attendu d'avoir plus de 715
sur ces territoires ultramarins pour
accepter votre aide bon vous serez
chaque pays a ses propres compétences
la façon de les laisser décider nous ont
respectés au respect on a le respect
pour la façon dont les quais les autres
pays travaillent les autorités les deux
font des régions et nous sommes prêts à
agir on l'a fait déjà que vous l'avez
mentionné avec un certain nombre de pays
qui ont demandé de l'aide de nos
médecins et actuellement nous sont des
mecs en prêchant ton pays de l'amérique
latine des caraïbes même en europe
le est mentionné à l'italie en andorre
alors notre notre capacité de
réchauffement et l'inde sont prêts à
aider ceux qui nous demandent de la
coopération pour faire face à cette
épidémie
les médecins cubains se sont déployés
dans près de 40 pays dans le monde vous
l'avez dit beaucoup de pays
font appel à vous pourquoi selon vous on
voit l'argent beaucoup investi les 60
dernières années dont six concernent
l'information des ressources humains y
compris dans le secteur de la médecine
plus de 400000 mixtape pour soins de la
santé des titans a travaillé depuis les
années 60 donc plus de ça change à 100
pays du monde
nous sommes formés à cuba plus de 35000
maixent gouvernants des pays du
tiers-monde avant l'épidémie de prix
jean r
on avait plus aidé en me levant 9000
collaborateurs qui va de la santé qui
travaillent et dont plus de 65 pays du
monde parce qu'on a ce potentiel vous
l'avez mentionné nous avons plus d'élus
95 mille médecins akiba net mais
ressemble par 1000 habitants
ce que je veux dire que nous allons le
réchauffement pour assurer la santé
publique et notre population et en même
temps pour aider ceux qui ont des
difficultés à faire face à des épidémies
dégâts chez les cas actuellement
justement cette crise sanitaire ce que
c'est l'occasion pour cuba de retrouver
une place sur la selle sur la scène
internationale
on appelle un les accords négociés par
barack obama ont été rognés 1 par donald
trump notamment bon nous nous sommes
très pression de la scène internationale
le son un pays très active au niveau des
nations unies nous serons des relations
diplomatiques avec 193 pays membres de
la communauté internationale nous
saurons plus descendante ambassades
partout dans le monde
121 à 125 30 états on descend d'assad à
laval et mais non c'est une ovation pour
réitérer renforcer notre volonté d'être
solidaire avec champions deschamps y
compris mais non pour faire face à cette
épidémie
mais c'est pas rien de nouveau cela fait
partie de notre politique étrangère des
déchets qui y ont des difficultés pour
avoir affronté des défis quelqu'un où
l'avortement est ce qu'il ya un savoir
faire
particulier de la part de cubains en
terme de crise épidémique
oui nous sommes ancrés depuis l'année
2005 des brigades médical spécialisé
dans les cas des catastrophes et des
piscines des épidémies se change du
personnel de la santé médecins des
infirmières des techniciens de la santé
qui ont donné de l'aide de la
coopération à des pays dont les cas des
tabliers catastrophe aurait semble à
l'occasion des tremblements de terre en
haïti au ton des catastrophes naturelles
comme des inondations
vous vous souvenez sûrement à l'occasion
de l'épidémie d'ebola en afrique
occidentale
nous avons eu aussi envoyer des médecins
qui ont aidé la population les
populations de ces pays à faire face à
cette épidémie
en effet on a un que de savoir faire et
nous le mettons aussi à l'exposition des
pays qu'on a envie j'en ai lu rodriguez
perdomo lorsque cette crise sanitaire
sera derrière nous lorsqu'ils le découle
le confinant ce sera fini
le fait d'avoir aidé une quarantaine de
pays est ce que derrière vous vous
attendez à un renvoi d'ascenseur de la
part des autres pays notamment les
grandes puissances de ce monde notamment
la france ou l'italie qui font partie du
g7 mais que nous attendons chez on l'a
dit c'est il faut tout faire face aux
défis du monde actuel il faut être
solide et il faut être capable d'aider
les autres il n'y a pas d'autre façon d
agir dans le contexte international
actuel nous donnons ce qui est en notre
capacité en tant que petit pays parce
que nous avons les restes humains
nous attendons rien réponse ce que nous
attendons c'est une culasse coopération
internationale plus large celle héritée
pour faire face tous ensemble aux grands
défis du monde actuel
merci lui rodriguez perdomo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes l'ambassadeur de cuba en
france